hey youtubers it's Charlie big news the
flash is back this week and they're
finishing filming the finale most of the
cast is almost on finishing episode 23
so far I've only seen danielle Panabaker
tweet you know had my last day on the
flash this season it's been awesome I'll
see you guys next season it doesn't mean
that they're completely done filming the
finale it's just that certain actors
finished their final scenes before other
actors so like Grant Gustin might have a
whole bunch of other berry scenes to
film for the finale so not everybody's
done yet but they're really close David
Ramsey also did the same thing where he
tweeted last day on arrow season 4 can't
wait til season 5 Stephen Amell still
riding his tricycle around setting up
shots so a couple days left before arrow
and flash go on break for the summer now
the funny thing about that - maybe I'll
talk about it a little bit at the end of
the video is that just because the
actors rap doesn't mean that the show
stops working because the writers will
start pitching next season so there's so
much exciting stuff happening but Jay
Garrick or Teddy Sears or zoom or
however you want to think about him the
actor who plays zoom was teasing things
about the finale
he talked about the mystery of the man
in the iron mask we learned that he's
not actually gonna take that iron mask
off till the finale but I think by that
time we'll have a pretty good idea of
who he is next week's episode is all
about zooms backstory explaining how he
became so crazy so I think that'll give
us a lot more clues about who's in the
iron mask
but right now before having seen any of
the final episodes I'll say you know the
best theory I've seen is that it's the
true version of Jay Garrick we've seen
the trailer for next week's episode but
just to explain what the flash is doing
it's actually really cool they're kind
of doing their version of a crime serial
next week where they explain how a
normal person turns into a serial killer
if you are a big fan of crime serials
it's a little closer to that Netflix
series how to make a murderer than it is
to like the jinx the jinx is that HBO
series about Robert Durst it's a good
example of how a psychopath like a real
psychopath with unlimited money can
escape the law and on the flip side of
that how to make a murderer is a good
example of how the law can railroad the
poor now the flash isn't doing any of
those stories literally or anything like
that it's just asking the question
what would have happened to Barry had
his life been super shitty now he had
some shitty things happen to him but he
had good people around him he had Joe
take him in what would have happened to
Barry if he didn't have any of those
good things in his life that's going to
next week's episode explaining how soom
turned into a serial killer because he
didn't have any of those good things or
any of those good people helping him out
so part of the fun is gonna be actually
watching those moments flashing back to
zooms life seeing him in this Hannibal
Lecter op that in prison already I'm
seeing some flashpoint Easter eggs here
then once they explain zoom the real job
is finding whether or not there's a
solution to this do they contain him do
they fix him is there a way to fix them
is that even possible like is berry
gonna go back in time and change his
past so that something good happens to
him because that's also super risky two
times we found out really bad things
happen when you time-travel one you Bart
Thawne told us the time will replace you
know whatever it is that you're trying
to skip over was something that's just
as bad
so if Barry goes back in save zoom
something bad will still end up
happening to zoom at a certain point in
number two we also learned about time
rates which is kind of like the TV shows
version of the black flash Barry going
back in time to save hunter zolomon
as a child save them from something bad
happening to him could also cause more
immediate problems for Barry in the form
of a time Wraith so let me know in the
comments you know without having seen
the rest of the episodes is there a way
Barry could go back in time and fix
zooms past fix hunter Zola mods past so
that he doesn't turn into zoom or do you
think that hunter zolomon
is gonna end up like trajectory and just
get absorbed into the Speed Force as
pure energy because he takes too much
velocity-9 usually when you think about
finales you have to think about like
what the most spectacular and satisfying
conclusion is so one it has to look
awesome and two it has to feel like it
makes sense so I feel like you could
redeem zoom with some really careful
time-travel I think the more cynical
scenario and one that's also pretty
thrilling is that he just goes up in a
blaze of speed for glory and gets turned
into pure energy just gets absorbed into
the Speed Force
that way he could totally come back in a
future season he could ream aterial eyes
this energy in the form of another
person what I'd really like to see them
do though is resolve the finale in a way
that fixes the Jay Garrick character so
that we get a good version of Jay
Garrick that can work with Barry Allen
and a lot of that is going to depend on
whether or not the man in the iron mask
is the real Jay Garrick because if a
real version of Jay Garrick exists then
you can kill off hunters olomana in a
really spectacular way without losing
Jay Garrick but
if hunter zolomon is the only version of
jay garrick on earth - then you have to
find a way to fix them so that you can
still use jay garrick but the other
really cool thing that's coming up is
Kevin Smith's episode he's been teasing
the end of it
so I'm gonna explain what he said and
what I think it means so just careful
for potential spoilers for stuff that's
coming up he said some very vague things
but it was pretty easy to figure out
what he was saying so he directed
episode 21 we know episode 22 is gonna
be the black siren episode with Katie
Cassidy episode 23 is the finale so he
said the teaser at the end of his
episode is this wide shot of all these
villains lined up with zoom so what I
think that means is that zoom is just
going to lead an all-out assault with
many many metahumans on earth one
sometime in episode 22 or episode 23 he
didn't really specify how it was
happening like if Cisco was vibing all
these villains teaming up or if somebody
else was looking at it or if it was like
a cut to scene and nobody on team flash
knew that it was happening but it just
means there's going to be a big battle
royale sometime in the last couple of
episodes and that makes me wonder if
that's gonna happen in episode 22
if black siren is gonna be in that big
lineup the big teaser at the end of
episode 21 so just put a bookmark in
that for now because that episode is
still weeks and weeks away we're only on
episode 18 right now the flash arrow
still on break this week so in two weeks
when we get flash episode 19 right after
that will be arrow episode 19 the
episodes won't be out of order anymore
but giveaway time there's a new round to
the DC giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card I'll be doing another DC video
later tonight for the Batman solo film
so I'll just remind everyone whenever I
post that and I know they just announced
a new big speedster villain in the
comics but I'm not quite ready to talk
about that it's not super relevant to
what's going on the flash TV show right
now the new villain is gonna be called
Godspeed has a really interesting origin
story so I'll talk about him in a future
video while you guys wait for me to post
that video you can click here to watch
the Winter Soldier run the Avengers
gauntlet and you can click here to learn
all about the spider-man solo film
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight